Yeah,
oh,
it's an appalling ideology because the
people who created it had the idea about
what it should be before they made it.
So it's propaganda.
You can say exactly what frozen is
about.
So it's propaganda.
A truly mythologically based story.
You can never fully say what it's about.
You can just talk about it forever and
ever and ever and ever.
So it's,
it's a wellspring of meaning,
so.
Oh sure they are.
Of course that's what they're doing.
Oh yeah,
it's calculated marketing.
Yeah.
Yeah,
sure.
It was hyper politically correct.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
And they didn't need men and you know,
God,
give me a break,
you know,
just because you need men doesn't mean
you have to like them.
Yeah.
So,
so I mean I thought a lot about the
difference between propaganda and art.
So art actually a process rather than an
end product and with any luck if you
have a piece of art,
the process is embedded in the byproduct
and so it reflects the process when you
bring it into your house.
And so it's an active,
it's a,
it's a crystallized active exploration
and the real artist doesn't know what
they're doing.
They don't know what they're doing.
They're exploring.
I can,
I can recommend a film.
There's a film made of Picasso wouldn't
boat 1957 and it was a black and white
film and it was actually a film of him
making a painting and he painted it on
glass so you could see what he was
doing.
It's really quite fascinating because
you can see that he's playing,
he sketches it in and then he rubs it
out so then he sketches it in again and
he rubs it out and he sketches over here
and it's like there's a real dynamism
about it.
He doesn't plan it out to begin with.
Not that there's necessarily anything
wrong with that as an artistic endeavor
to.
But PAGASA was trying to explore and
understand and you know,
I don't know what you knew about cubism,
but cubism.
It's a strange thing.
But what he was doing with his cubism
was to try to show you that you only see
things from one perspective,
but the things exist in multiple
perspective,
so you know,
a cubist painting is your face this way
and your face this way at the same time.
And so you could say,
well,
is that a more accurate way of of
representing a person that just the
standard portrait and Picasso would say,
well in some ways definitely because it
captures the transformative element
rather than the static element.
And so someone who's a true artist
doesn't have a political message.
And it's funny because my house is full
of ideological propaganda from the
Soviet Union.
It's just packed full of it and it's so
interesting to watch these artifacts
because a lot of them were socialist
realist,
although mostly they're impressionist.
Really.
It's so interesting to watch them
because in that painting themselves,
there is a war that you can perceive and
the war is a lot of the people who made
these paintings were incredibly
talented,
really,
really skilled because the Russians kept
their.
Their Formula Academy's open so the can
really paint impressionism.
It's remarkable,
but their talents were encapsulated
within this what mostly this ideology
and so in each canvas there's this war
between the ideological message and the
artistic message and what's so cool is
the farther we get away from the Soviet
Union,
the more the art winds,
because in 300 years there isn't going
to be a shred left of that ideology and
all that will be left to the paintings
is the art,
so
part of the reason that people are so
attracted to art is because the artist
actually manifests identity with the
process of transformation and so that's
why the artist is a cultural hero.
That's also why every nihilist worth his
salt wants to be an artist like,
who are you?
What are you going to say?
I'm a nihilist snow.
I'm an artist.
It's like,
no,
you're not,
but I can see why you want to be.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Just because you're a failure,
it doesn't mean you're an artist.
Right.
Well,
I think it depends on who you are.
Like,
it's really interesting to me,
but I'm really interested enough,
you know,
and I'm also interested in the way that
ideologies coopt more fundamental
processes to,
to,
and harness their energy as a,
as a rational and motivating force.
And so for me,
these pieces of art propaganda are
extremely interesting.
I mean,
it's very interesting to be surrounded
by them because I can see this war going
on all the time.
So it's very cool.
And there are twinning far as I can
tell,
so that's very interesting because they
were pure propaganda,
many of them when I bought them.
But it's getting farther and farther
away from the Soviet Union.
So the more architectural elements are
coming to the forefront.